now I just want to point out this
formula this is not part of the course
but I still want you to understand the
way it works and I still want you to
write it now okay so this is a formula
for working out the number of standard
drinks that you have drank based on two
different things let me give you the
formula first and stands for bad number
off standard drinks you've got this
funny number at the front which people
worked out with some crazy science and
then you've got two other bits relevant
to it you already know what they are
what do you think they stand for these
days for volume like how much what
quantity have you drink so volume of
drink and what do you think
hey now this is just about what you have
instead of time I've consumed so a
stands for alcohol by boy okay so it's
going to be a percentage right okay
so for instance let's suppose eg let's
suppose you've drunk you know a standard
scooters what for or 70 or so like that
bills and I've drank say three of those
and the alcohol content was something
like say oh we said 5% let's go one
point two like I said one point two
liters so I this I should have said
actually is in Lea's
and this percentage over here this
percentage is not to be confused with on
alcohol content which is always it's
like point or whatever okay it's a
number like this 5/3 or 13 it's a whole
number and the percentage is included
okay so I think we sent out by person
like I started Peter is about five
percent okay so good number for me I
write five five just a token someone
like that I mean five times one point
two is six
that's about point a I'm guessing
something like four and a half between
four and a half and five okay so you can
see my um you know like say three
glasses right there were tall glasses so
that's why they've worked out to be more
than three standard drinks okay so it's
really important that you get that a
standard rate is not necessarily one
glass whatever you're drinking out of it
can be something quite different based
on concentration okay so then what do we
do with standard tricks do remember I
asked you to open up the reference sheet
I want you to turn to it now and
aesthetics they're not out there to make
it convenient for you to work out my
stated Riki's no I don't think it's a
concern is their concern it's our job as
the to drink responsibly right that's
why it says okay you got the foam and
dodge it then have a look
scroll score swollen to you think you
see something that is relevant oh yeah
that might be useful okay here we go so
this is on page I think it's on page
three now what are these two note here
can you just put your pins on your hand
and look at the formulas plural with me
number one there are two formulas why
okay as you put it out whether you are
better would this changes how quickly
your body goes through okay now then you
can see this three numbers here three
numbers they aren't defined for you okay
so and we've already worked out that's
the number Senate Reese you have H
stands for hours what is this matter the
longer you've been drinking the longer
your body has had the opportunity to go
ahead and process that alcohol right
which is why it's take away that right
do you see as H gets bigger and bigger
we got one hour two hours three hours of
passed okay then this whole number is
gonna get smaller it's gonna reduce your
blood alcohol content because your
body's been actually trying to work with
it that's your livers job okay then
you've got this M on the bottom right M
stands for that's right this is why I
pointed out not just touches called wait
call it mass because the formulas gonna
use it this way
and do you notice the M is on the bottom
of the it's on the denominator of these
formulas in each case what does that
mean as you get heavier right how does
that affect the whole number if the
denominator is getting bigger if the
denominator is getting bigger the whole
number is getting smaller right so the
more you weigh the less it's actually
going to have a total effect on your
blood alcohol content okay now last
thing to point out is please be careful
there are two the question will always
tell you whether you're dealing with a
moon woman one of those common errors in
the HSC
is that people just look at the first
formula because it's the first one they
see regardless of her tomato orbit and
they just kind of ignore oh yeah there's
two different ones okay
what's the difference between them it's
just that no really denominator right do
you notice the female at number is
smaller what does that do it means your
blood alcohol content will be higher for
all the same numbers for a corresponding
male because can you see the denominator
is smaller so the whole number is bigger